hello everybody and welcome to part 17
of let's play amnesia the Dark Descent
as last time we just discovered that our
orbit useless ow oh stop it ah
got it we got here go away win no one
likes you
you're stupid yeah I showed it right
that monster I'm on should bring it not
any more oil ah I got a head up where am
I airing the head 18:39 I don't believe
what I have become I can one of the
girls escaped alike chased after all the
way upstairs I'm sure you did hunted her
down and murdered her
like what nothing how many lives can I
take before I surrender my own a billion
cuz you're sure we cannot murder her to
save an innocent yeah right but to kill
an innocent to save myself a
cold-blooded murderer yeah no kidding
what jerk Daniel he's probably dying in
a hope
Oh machinery ah god machine whatever
you
we looks good and burn that
all right
Oh ha yeah dog will pick you up
baba baba rock rock might do huh
like all other things in amnesia row a
rock at it who you owe
huh okay all right yeah bleeding again
got such a fancy Oh
I heard something did you guys hear some
no probably not
but just in case okay that was something
good chair hmm no oh that's somebody not
afraid because I was afraid every other
time doesn't mean I'm afraid now you
can't come here face me I'm Way too
tough hardcore man our core
yeah yeah yes right you don't even know
yeah yeah walk away
I'm Way too tough manly and handsome
were you you ugly and wimpy yeah keep
walking walking walk walk what are you
gonna do nothing
yeah you too Quinn that's creepy
but you're not the environment is you'd
be a lot scarier if you were like on a
rainbow a lot less scary ow why I think
I need to go that way means I can take
him on in combat
time to die monster get ready to be
destroyed
I'd say bring it on all gone
mysteriously that's what I thought yeah
what have you got nothing no aah my orb
no no um I spent like half the game
trying to get that whatever ah boy
yeah oh right Inner Sanctum bath time I
heard about this like a first scene of
the game uh-huh
okay all right bring it on oh wait cause
ah you
ah no no no ha give me God Gabba Yo
Gabba Gabba
ha ha ha ha all right nope that's still
there don't cry here cooking Alexander I
will kill you for what you have done
how about yourself only the shadow would
caught me in London or Algeria I
wouldn't have to suffer this humiliation
to the humiliation made me a murderer
a monster yeah he did now oh poor baby
weak to press on oh we're we can hardly
stand as my knees fail me oh I cannot
see as my eyes at rest in tears my mask
that's we're o'connor's the man I've
tortured uh-huh
if only I could wipe my bear away as we
did with them no I'm pretty sure you
were scared the whole time ah no oh ah
stop sticking yourself with stuff Daniel
I know you're depressed
but why bah
ah hi no no no okay now something poke
yourself again jammer I jerk
liebherr ah see oh you can stab yourself
Wham
it's you deserve it like leg light why
cuz you deserve to walk around in the
dark and I stockpile too many anyway
yeah let's go rob red oh yeah that's
probably some sort of ritual weather
weirdoes
let me out open go will not open
why not oh yeah thanks up the great
advice journal assume Daniels writing it
be cheered book I'm Sammy ha ha ha ha ba
ha I said the magic word o open Oh leave
her leave her leave her
Oh nope
yeah what's going on not right
ah
open up search for a way to open
I'm trying okay I get it yeah it's shaky
dongdong ah stop it
hold it together Daniel give me together
give me together all right okay hold on
whoa hey hey doom
okay all right Daniel yeah whoa whoa
Daniel take it easy I lost a lot of odds
sticking your hand on that thing so much
uh look
open the door open it book look look Oh
Daniel stop it you're losing it you're
losing it you're losing it you're just
about to lose it oh there you go oh hey
oh man oh I shouldn't have those
margaritas uh-oh
I got stick my hands more
and we're back alright lady lady say the
magic words
ah oh did I do it
uh-huh I don't know how or what ah
everywhere Oh am I hurt ah Danna
okay ba ba la get up get up stop ah not
in the face ah damn it I'm killing me
I'm so close yeah oh yeah oh yeah I'm
the best ah
get away get away get away get away get
away why ah orbit chamber ah sounds good
oh right what have we got here
oh I'm gonna stop it real quick